it's been more than a year since Ford
introduced the 6th generation Mustang
which means it's time for the automaker
to start rolling out the special
editions and powered up variants it just
couldn't help but built we're glad it
gave in to that impulse because this is
the latest result the shelby gt350 our
mustang ford cut weight out of the gt350
are by tossing unnecessary features like
the air conditioner stereo and rear
seats the gt350 r is powered by a flat
plane crank shaft design that's car
jargon for a setup commonly used by
Ferrari to make a lighter higher revving
engine the 5.2 liter v8 is one of the
most powerful Ford units of all time and
the only trade-off is a louder more
rumbly engine that is a very good thing
ford also gifted the gt350 are a new
suspension that adjusts the feel at each
wheel a thousand times a second to adapt
to the road surface that improves
handling and keeps the car steady and
planted through tight turns a nice
surprise in a muscle car or it hasn't
released a zero to 60 time but I'm
willing to bet this pony's boat loads
faster than whatever's in your driveway
with a variety of settings from sport to
track to traction control completely off
the new Mustang will make any driver
look or at least feel like a master with
the suede wrapped racing wheel in their
hands